some of the rise of Skywalker's biggest
surprises happen in a Lightspeed flash
that's why we're here to run down the
biggest surprise cameos in the movie
from original trilogy sidekicks to
behind the camera architects the dead
speak proclaims the rise of Skywalker's
opening crawl making it clear as soon as
possible that things are about to get
weird and weird they do indeed get as we
find kylo Ren arriving at the planet x--
ago in response to a mysterious
broadcast from the somehow alive Sith
Lord and Emperor sheev Palpatine a
broadcast heard on planet Earth
exclusively as a fortnight
cross-promotion at last the work of
generations is complete the great is
corrected Ren finds Palpatine but that's
no surprise
we've known since the movies first
trailer that he'd be back more
unexpected are the cameos from other
past antagonists particularly because of
the unusual form they take when
Palpatine introduces himself as every
voice you've ever heard inside your head
his voice shape shifts briefly into that
of Supreme Leader Snoke and then that of
Darth Vader sure enough both Andy Serkis
and James Earl Jones lend their menacing
pipes to the illusion Snoke even appears
a moment later in the flesh nothing but
the flesh actually with parts of
seemingly rejected clone bodies floating
in a tank like a savory snoke's do it's
surprising to see Harrison Ford in rise
of Skywalker for a few reasons sure
there's the fact that non Jedi have
never appeared as force ghosts in the
movie before an issue the film skirts by
presenting Han Solo as a figment of his
wayward son's memory rather than an
actual Spectre there's also ford's
infamous annoyance with the legacy of
Star Wars he unsuccessfully campaigned
to get solo killed off in Return of the
Jedi and will take great pleasure in
telling you he doesn't care who shot
first it was surprising enough when it
was first announced that he would star
in the force awakens and downright
shocking to see him pop up again in Rise
of Skywalker but Ford seems to enjoy
working with Adam driver and we can
guess he probably liked the idea of
paying tribute to Carrie Fisher that's
why it's easy to overlook what could
have been a role worthy fanservice from
the moment we knew that the
Skywalker would revisit the Endor system
we had to wonder if we'd be seeing some
a walks
sadly the wreckage of the second Death
Star isn't actually on the same forest
moon we visited in Return of the Jedi
but on endures ocean moon heroes big
knife chase brings them into contact
with their new friend Jana and our very
good space horses but sadly the Avenger
remains devoid of killer bears that is
at least until the movie's grand finale
as the final order fleet falls a montage
much like the one added to the special
edition of Return of the Jedi brings us
to a few planets to witness the Galactic
victory celebration that's when we're
reintroduced to wicket played once again
by Star Wars mainstay Warwick Davis who
was just 11 years old the first time he
got zipped up into a teddy bear costume
on episode 6 alongside him is wicked son
Tom it played by Warwick's real-life son
Harrison wedge antilles is something of
a Star Wars good-luck charm having
survived all three major battles of the
original trilogy he was always there
when Luke and the Rebel Alliance needed
him even if he never took up a lot of
screen time the character would go on to
play a major role in plenty of Expanded
Universe material endearing him to a
generation of super fans it was
surprising then that wedge didn't make
an appearance in the force awakens at
the time actor Denis Lawson was quoted
as saying he turned down an offer to
appear because it would have quote board
him the actor later backtracked these
comments claiming that he would have
accepted the role if not for scheduling
conflicts whatever the case he's there
for a brief moment in rise of
Skywalker's climactic space battle
Manning a gun turret on the Millennium
Falcon it's Star Wars tradition for
behind the scenes crew members to make
blink and you'll miss them on-screen
cameos the rise of skywalker continues
this tradition of giving incidental
background roles to hard-working
creative types director JJ Abrams
provides the stuttering voice of
skittish droid do while his episode 9
co-writer Chris Terrio can be heard as
Aftab Akbar the squid-like son of the
beloved Admiral who perished during the
events of the last Jedi most
significantly composer John Williams can
briefly be seen as oma Trey the
bartender at the Kazumi dive where are
heroes find Babu Frick as the rise of
Skywalker begins we learned that Rey has
been continuing her Jedi training under
Leia focusing specifically on the effort
to commune with the spirits of past Jedi
communication through the force has been
a specialty of Leia's ever since the
Empire Strikes Back before she was even
aware of her own abilities still despite
her training Rey remains frustrated and
unable to hear any voices until her most
desperate moment during the film's
climax she lies nearly defeated at the
feet of Palpatine that's when
generations of Jedi finally talk back
offering her encouragement and support
some like Yoda
Anakin mace windu obi-wan Kenobi and
qui-gon jinn are pretty obvious but in
the chaos of the big final battle it was
probably hard to make all those voice
cameos out here's a quick rundown of the
more obscure voices of Jedi past
featured in the sequence Hoddy Galia
first appeared in The Phantom Menace but
most fans know her best from the
animated Star Wars the Clone Wars series
similarly Luminara Unduli and Aayla
Secura first appeared in attack of the
clones but both are best known from
Clone Wars ahsoka tano is also from
Clone Wars but the rise of Skywalker is
the character's live-action debut
technically even if we only hear her
voice the same goes for kanan jarrus
from Star Wars rebels meaning former
teen heartthrob Freddie Prinze jr. or
his voice at least is in the rise of
skywalker talk about a surprising cameo
what was that I was busy yeah busy
Wiggin excuse me I did not wait that was
major wig äj-- check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Star Wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]